hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
one of the most important developments
and
concepts that friedrich nietzsche is
going to narrate
and explore for us in his genealogy of
morals
particularly in essay 1
is what he calls the slave revolt in
morality
and this is closely associated with
another
key idea that uh verizontimont
and it's it's it's he says it flows
out of this there are a few things that
we want to
keep in mind before we jump in and look
at precisely what he has to say about
this
so slave morality or
herd morality however we want to talk
about it nietzsche has
very many ways of discussing this
platonism for the masses
you know is christianity right
christianity is a form of
this this morality um he's not
excluding many other modern
things as well many of the men of
science fit into this
depending on how they orient themselves
even you know
those who are focused on
sort of an economic basis for things
and viewing everything in terms of
utility or
what they can buy for it if they are
champions of capitalism they may
actually be part of slave morality
just as much as socialists or
those in favor of democracy all these
things nietzsche sees as fitting into
slave morality
early on in the essay he's not
discussing it
in any sort of expansive sense like that
because he's really really interested
in where this comes from
and we can say that at the beginning
there isn't any actually slave morality
a morality is something that's an
achievement
something that develops and so
originally there's a primary valuation
which nietzsche sometimes calls master
morality
or you know the aristocratic noble
way of understanding these things and
that's that's what's there and then we
have the emergence of the priest
and a different kind of valuation and
then we have the
common people who have been dis valued
by this this uh
master morality and then something new
happens we have the emergence or the
explosion of the
slave morality this slave revolt
right and they're not revolting just to
change material circumstances
they're not revolting just to change
being treated like
equals or anything like that what
they're actually doing is changing the
culture
itself and in effect taking it over
so this is this is an important
development according to nietzsche and
what we really have here is the clash
of two different kinds of moral
valuation the master morality
is self-assertive it views the masters
as good it values them as such it makes
a judgment about them
and it dis values the others
the commoners as bad not as evil but
as as bad as weak and
you know with the priest we have the
pure versus the impure we have a
sort of clash with the aristocratic
motive valuation but it's really with
the common people
that we find um this this developing in
a way that can
can do something so he talks in chapter
10
about the slave revolt in morality
as being something that it you know
brings something new into existence
and so he says the slave revolt and
morality
begins when resentment itself becomes
creative and gives birth to
values gives birth to new ways of
valuing
people actions uh institutions all those
sorts of things
and he tells us that the result amount
of natures that are denied the true
reaction that of deeds
and compensate themselves with an
imaginary revenge now a little bit later
on
in that very chapter he'll talk about
how resonte mont isn't just something
that the lower class has or the priests
have
the nobles can have it but it's a little
bit different he says
if it should appear in the noble man it
consummates and exhausts itself in an
immediate reaction
therefore does not poison and so what we
can say is that
with the priest and with the common
people
resontaman poisons and that's part of
what makes it
creative another really important aspect
here
he tells us that the no is its creative
deed
it's refusal it's rejection of something
and so it's it's bringing something new
into being a new configuration a new
mindset
by saying no by negating
something else which makes it reactive
according to nietzsche
so we what we have here is action as
reaction so as opposed to the nobles
who just as the strong kind of
instinctively
engage with each other fighting with
each other rivaling with each other
and then also turn towards the common
people you know suppressing them
stealing things from them
uh raping pillaging whatever it's going
to be exploiting them
and then towards the external enemy they
show themselves as
totally um you know brutal
uh and this is all you know sort of
agency
in this case it's it's just simply
reaction
on the part of those who are filled with
resentment
he tells us that the here's the passage
this inversion of the value positing i
this need to direct one's view
outward instead of back to oneself is
of the essence of risantomont
in order to exist slave morality first
needs a hostile external world
it needs physiologically st see
speaking external stimuli in order to
act at all
its action is fundamentally reaction so
this is a
you know very important note uh what is
what is the outward facing focus
it's toward a hostile world this world
is so you know
sucky it's uh unfair why did things have
to be this way
and towards the strong the people who
actually
do things who exert their force
within that that world so the hostile
world and the strong are really
in some respect connected with each
other
and slave morality focuses on that and
then
then says i'm not like that those are
bad
actually not just bad but evil
and i am something different
so we can talk about persons that are
filled with resentment nature
identifies the priest earlier in uh
chapters uh leading up to this as a
person
of resentment right the priest turns
inward
and does so out of impotence they don't
come out well in physical confrontations
with the warriors
but this is also something of the common
people especially
as the common people gain some measure
of control or power over parts of their
life which could still be capriciously
taken away
by the the nobles intervening and doing
things that they don't like
but there are these these people of
resentment and then nietzsche
characterizes them in some
very important ways
um he tells us that um
while the noble person lives in trust
and openness with themselves
the person of resentment and notice all
the negatives here that nietzsche has
right so
it's it's uh not just that they bring
negation
they are also negations of what it is to
be noble
they're not upright um they're not naive
they
they think through their reactions they
have to consider things because
otherwise the nobles may crush them
right
they're not honest or straightforward
with themselves
they not only lie to the nobles they lie
to each other and they lie to themselves
sometimes not totally lying but you know
partial lies
where there's a bit of truth and a bit
of lie mixed in together
and he says his soul squints
his spirit loves hiding places secret
paths and back doors
everything covert entices him as his
world his security his refreshment
he understands how to keep silent how
not to forget how to wait
how to be provisionally self-deprecating
and humble
and what he's talking about there is
this concealment that
has to take place and this becomes part
of their
culture it becomes part of their
instinctual approaches it becomes
habitude and then he goes a little bit
further and he says
a race of such menarizontamont is bound
to become
eventually cleverer than any
noble race right klugeit is the german
this cleverness this
you know being able to figure things out
and that's connected with concealment
in this as opposed to the
openness and naivete of the nobles
he says it will honor cleverness to a
far greater degree
as a condition of existence of the first
importance
while with noblemen cleverness can
easily acquire a subtle flavor of luxury
and and subtlety for here it is less
essential
right uh in in the case of of the person
of rizontamont
cleverness is really needed
and so this is
something really quite essential
now he goes on and he talks about this
what he'll
later identify as a trans valuation
taking place of values and what's the
contrast here so originally
we have the strong self-defining
themselves as good
and in this case the
strong are valued now by the man of
resentment or the race of resentment or
the you know weird mixture of the priest
and the commoner the strong become
the evil the people who do bad things
you know and do them because they're
cruel they do them because they're
underdeveloped
they do them because they have evil
within their hearts
now then the
weak the people of resontamont
can redefine themselves as well they
were viewed as bad
by the nobles by the noble form of
morality
now they can call themselves good but
notice
that there's a really fundamental
distinction here
the strong self-defined themselves as
good they defined good
first and then they defined that
as against the bad so the opposition is
first i define myself then i define you
scum over there
in the case of the weak
the common people first they define
what's evil
and then they negatively define what's
good as not being
evil when nietzsche by the way talks
about going beyond good and evil this is
what he's rejecting he's not rejecting
good versus bad
he's rejecting good versus evil and so
there's this entire um transformation
or trans valuation we can call it that
is taking place
there's a very important set of passages
in chapter 14
where he talks about the secret of how
ideals are made
on earth let's take a look at it he says
and what do we find so
he says i see nothing but i hear all the
more there's a soft weary malignant
muttering and whispering coming from all
corners and nooks
it seems to me one is lying weakness is
being lied into something meritorious no
doubt of it
it is just as you said and impotence was
which does not requite into goodness of
heart anxious lowliness into humility
subjection to those one hates into
obedience that is to one
of whom they they say he commands this
objection they call him god
the inoffensiveness of the weak man even
the cowardice of which he has so much is
lingering at the door
all of these things acquire flattering
names like patience and are called
virtue itself so the the the traits of
the common person the fawning
uh in unable to defend himself or to
assert himself person
are being turned into positive character
traits it's no longer
just a generic sense of goodness these
ideals that he's talking about are
quite important and now he talks about a
very important one
his inability for revenge is called
unwillingness to revenge perhaps even
forgiveness they also speak of loving
one's enemies
so the person who can't actually
retaliate
who can't reimpose some sort of
measure or order or relation with the
other person who has to suck it up
and take it says oh i could go after the
other person i choose not to because i'm
the better
person i'm a good person by doing that
right so unwillingness is what what
impotence looks like
he goes on and he says they're miserable
all these mutterers and nook
counterfeiters
though they crouch warmly together but
they tell me their misery is a sign of
being chosen
by god one beats the dogs one likes best
perhaps this misery is also a
preparation attesting a schooling
perhaps it's more
something that will one day may be made
good and recompensed with interest
with huge payments of gold no of
happiness they call this bliss
so misery gets transformed into being
chosen gets transformed
into its opposite of misery happiness
beatitude right again there's there's a
lying
going on here according to nietzsche
then there's a
another important thing he says
here we go now they give me to
understand they're not merely better
than the mighty the lords of the earth
whose spittle they have to lick
they are not merely better better but
also better off or at least will be
better off someday
but then there's something else and
nietzsche says no wait a minute you've
said nothing of the masterpiece of these
black magicians
who make whiteness milk and innocence of
every blackness haven't you noticed
their perfection of refinement
their boldest most artistic stroke
what is it what do they do with
revengefulness
and hatred what have they done with
these things they don't talk about
revenge and hatred anymore they talk
instead
about justice he says we
good men we are the just with what they
what they desire they call not
retaliation but the triumph of
justice what they hate is not their
enemy no they hate injustice
they hate godlessness what they believe
in and hope for is not the hope of
revenge
the intoxication of sweet revenge but
the victory of god the just god over the
godless
what there is left for them to love on
earth is not their brothers
in hatred but their brothers in love
and so nietzsche is saying these people
and
we don't have to necessarily have all
the god talk in there we can have
sort of a secular version of this but
people who are
saying oh no no i'm not motivated by a
desire for revenge i don't have hatred
towards anybody
nietzsche says that's bs you really do
you just
like to call it justice and you lie to
yourself about it it's all being
motivated
by resentment so this this gives us some
idea about what's going on with this
transformation this trans valuation this
this slave revolt
in morality how it embodies rizzontimont
it acts as a vehicle for it
and in the process you could say
develops it
fuller maybe to its fullest extent
and that becomes the motivating factor
in this type of morality according to
nietzsche
you